welcome back we're almost done learning
all the the rules or laws of angles that
we need to start playing the angle game
so let's just teach you a couple of more
so let's say i have two parallel lines
and you may not know what a parallel
line is and i i will explain it to you
now
so i have one line like this let's see a
parallel line and that you probably have
an intuition whatever parallel line
means
that's one that's one of my parallel
lines and let me make the green one the
other parallel line
so parallel lines and i'm just drawing
part of them we assume that they keep on
going forever because these are abstract
notions
this
light blue line keeps going and going on
and on and on off off the screen and
same for the screen line and parallel
lines are two lines in the same plane
and a plane is just kind of you know you
can kind of use like a flat surface as a
plane
um we won't go into you know you know
three-dimensional space in geometry
class
but uh they're on the same plane and you
can view this plane as the screen of
your computer right now or the piece of
paper you're working on
that never intersect each other and
they're two separate lines obviously if
they were drawn on top of the well on
top of each other then they they
intersect each other everywhere so it's
really just two lines on a plane that
never intersect each other that's a
parallel line if you've already learned
your algebra and you're familiar with
slope parallel lines are two lines that
have the same slope right they kind of
increase or decrease at the same rate
but they have different y-intercepts if
you don't know what i'm talking about
don't worry about it i think you know
what a parallel line means and you know
you've seen this parallel parking what's
parallel parking is when you park a a
car right next to another car without
having the two cars intersect because if
the cars did intersect you would have to
call your insurance company but anyway
so those are parallel lines the blue and
and and the green lines are parallel
and i will introduce you to a new
complicated geometry term called a
transversal all a transversal is
is another line that actually intersects
those two lines
that's a transversal fancy word for
something very simple transversal
let me write it down just to write
something down transversal
transversal
it crosses
the other two lines
uh i was thinking of mnemonics for
transversals but i probably was thinking
of things inappropriate but anyway
involving things that craw anyway
going on with the geometry but uh so we
have a transversal that intersects the
the two parallel lines and what we're
going to do is think of a bunch of and
actually if it intersects one of them
it's going to intersect the other and
and i'll let you think about that
there's there's no way that i can draw
something that intersects one parallel
line that doesn't intersect the other
as long as this line keeps going forever
and and i think that that might be
pretty obvious to you but what i want to
do is explore the angles of when a of a
transversal
so the first thing i'm going to do is
explore
the corresponding angles
so let's say corresponding angles are
kind of the same angle at each of the
parallel lines that's how i think of
them
so this angle
this angle
and this angle are corresponding angles
right because they they kind of play the
same role where the transversal
intersects each of the lines and as you
can imagine and as it looks from my
amazingly neat drawing i'm normally not
this good that these are going to be
equal to each other so this is x
this is also going to be x
and if we know that then we could use
actually the the rules that we we just
learned to figure out everything else
about all of these lines right because
if this is x then what is what is this
what is this going to be right here
what is this angle going to be
in magenta
well these are opposite angles right
they're on opposite sides of crossing
lines so this is also x
right and similar we can do the same
thing here this this is the opposite
angle of this angle so this is also
x this is also x
and what is
let me pick a good color
what is
yellow
what is this angle gonna be
well just like we were doing before look
we have this huge angle here right this
this angle is this whole angle is 180
degrees so you can cut x and this yellow
angle are supplementary
so we could call this you know we call
this angle y
and this is equal to
180
minus x
right
and we're just using supplementary
angles here well if this angle is y then
this this angle is opposite to y
so
this angle is also y
fascinating
and similarly if we have x up here and x
is supplementary to this angle as well
right
so this is equal to 180 minus x or it
also equals y
and then opposite angles this is also
equal to y
so there's all sorts of geometry
words and rules that fall out of this
and i'll review them real fast but it's
really nothing fancy all i did is i
started off with the notion of
corresponding angles i said well you
know this x is equal to this x
and i said oh well if that if those are
equal to each other well not even if i
mean if this is x and this is also x
because they're opposite
and same thing for this
and then well if this is x and this is x
and those equal each other and as they
should because those are also
corresponding angles because they these
two magenta angles are playing the same
role
right they're both kind of the bottom
left angle that's how i think about it
and we we went around we used
supplementary angles to kind of derive
well these y angles are also the same
this y angle is equal to this y angle
because they're corresponding this y
angle is equal to this y angle because
it's corresponding
so corresponding angles are equal to
each other then and it makes sense
they're kind of playing the same role
you know i kind of you know the bottom
right angle is equal to the bottom right
angle so corresponding angles are equal
corresponding
corresponding
angles are equal that's my shorthand
notation
and we've really just derived everything
already that's all you really have to
know but if you wanted to kind of skip a
step you also know the alternative
alternate interior angles
alternate
interior angles
angles
are
equal so what i mean by alternate
interior angles
well the interior angles are kind of the
angles that are that are closer to each
other and the two parallel lines and but
they're on opposite side of the
transversal that's a very complicated
way of saying this orange angle and this
magenta angle right here these are
alternate interior angles and we've
already proved if this is x then that is
x right so these are alternate interior
angles
this x
and then
that x our alternate interior and
actually this y
and this y are also alternate interior
and we already proved that they equal
each other and then the last term that
you're you're you'll see in geometry is
alternate i'm not going to write the
whole thing alternate exterior angles
alternate exterior angles are also equal
and that's the angles on the kind of
further away from each other on the
parallel lines and but they're still
alternate so that an example of that is
this x up here
and this x down here right because
they're on they're on they're they're
further they're on the outsides of the
two parallel lines right one's on top
one's on bottom and then they're on
opposite sides on alternate sides of the
transversal these are just fancy words
but i think hopefully you have the
intuition it's just you know
corresponding line corresponding angles
make the most sense to me and then
everything else proves out just through
opposite angles and supplementary angles
but alternate exterior
is that angle
and
that angle
and then the other alternate exterior is
this y and this y
and those are also equal so if you know
these you know pretty much everything
you need to know about parallel lines
now the last thing i'm going to teach
you in order to play the geometry game
with full force is just that the angles
in a triangle add up to 180 degrees
c
so let me just draw a triangle
of kind of random looking triangle
that's my random looking triangle
and if this is x
this is y
and this is z
we know that the angles of a triangle x
degrees plus y degrees plus z degrees
are equal to 180 degrees
so if i said that this is equal to i
don't know 30 degrees
this is equal to i don't know 70 degrees
then what does z equal well we would say
30
plus 70 plus z is equal to 180
or 100
plus z is equal to 180 subtract 100 from
both sides z would be equal to 80
degrees
and we'll see variations of this where
you know you get two of the angles and
you can use this property to figure out
the third
with everything we've now learned i
think we're ready to kind of ease into
the angle game i'll see you in the next
video